une fois de plus gisèle hébert rend
visite à son mari flavio dans un sachet
celle des publics
il souffre de démence et ses revenus
sont insuffisants pour payer chaque mois
les 1500 96 dollars que lui coûte la
chambre qu'elle partage avec une autre
personne reveal à moi je vis là lui à
des besoins
moi aussi j'en ai des besoins est ce que
la personne qui est à la maison est
obligé de vraiment ne plus vivre pour
faire vivre l'autre ça veut dire sont en
fin de compte il est possible de
diminuer le coût des loyers en ch et
celle des grâce au programme de
contributions financières administré par
la régie de l'assurance maladie du
québec
mais madame hébert à défaire des fonds
enregistré de revenu de retraite et elle
doit payer pour son mari dès qu'un
couple marié possède plus de 2500 $ ou
une maison de 40000 et plus il n'a plus
droit au programme paul brunet dirige le
conseil pour la protection des malades
les seuils au delà desquels vous comme
un sens contribuer date de 1983 votre
conjoint votre conjoint qui n'a pas être
hébergés elle ou lui il va être
contraint à la pauvreté assurément si
toutes les liquidités et tous les actifs
sont bons pour payer à contribution
d'indécence d'un juge d'ailleurs la
protectrice du citoyen réclame depuis
des années une intervention rapide du
gouvernement actuellement pour moi ces
critères ne sont pas acceptables en
raison de leur vétusté
la personne qui a de l'argent la capeb
c'est fini 1 on dit l'argent fait pas le
bonheur mais l'argent à supporter dans
ma lame si le gouvernement legault est
il prêt à bouger
on ne sait toujours pas la ministre
responsable du dossier marguerite blais
n'a pas voulu nous accorder une entrevue
ici yvan la montagne radio canada
montréal